ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE HEARING. LAST WEEK THE
ASSEMBLY LIFTED ALL SOCIAL
DISTANCING MEASURES AND I AM
HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL RETURNING TO IN
PERSON TESTIMONY ONLY AS
REFLECTED IN THE FINAL NOTICE.
WE HAVE ONE BILL TODAY THAT HAS
BEEN PRE APPROVED FOR CONSENT AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY RODRIGUEZ. AND I
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AS SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHICH IS
HOPEFULLY VERY SOON. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF RK HAND.
FINALLY WELL WE ONLY HAVE THREE
BILLS SCHEDULED FOR TODAY'S
HEARING IT IS IMPORTANT AT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FOR PROCEEDINGS IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE TOP TALKING
OR MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. IF AN INDIVIDUAL
DISRUPTS OUR HEARING PROCESS I
WILL DIRECT THEM TO STOP AND
WARNED THEM THAT CONTINUED
DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I ALSO DOCUMENT ON THE
RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED
IN THE NATURE OF THE DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT. CONDUCT I MAY
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF CONTACT DOES NOT
STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
ESCORTING. THE INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. THANK YOU
FOR COOPERATION THAT CONCLUDES
OUR DISCLAIMERS AND WE CAN NOW
CAN TURN TO THE ITEMS BEFORE US
TODAY SO I SEE THAT WE HAVE- MR
RAMA'S HERE WITH US. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST WE WOULD INVITE
YOU FOR.
WITH. WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM FIRST BUT THEY I
APPRECIATE YOUR EAGERNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SAYS A PERSONAL
INVITATION FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN TO COME JOIN US IN PRIVACY
. THANK YOU MR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND- THANK YOU FOR THE- MOTION
AND A SECOND WHEN THE TIMES
APPROPRIATE. I WANNA- THANK YOU-
AND WOULD LIKE TO START OFF BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US IN ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED
AND THEN ALICE'S. FAT NON OPIOID
OVERDOSES AND POISONINGS HAVE
BEEN A SCOURGE IN OUR DISTRICTS.
MANY OF THE VICTIMS ESPECIALLY
WITH FAT NOW HAVE NO IDEA. OF
THE POTENCY OF THE DRUGS WHICH
IS MANY TIMES MORE POWERFUL THAN
REGULAR OPIOIDS. NATIONALLY
OVERDOSES ROSE FROM TWO THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN TO A STARTLING
AMOUNT OF 310-003-0030 FIVE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES REPORTED OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND OVERDOSES
CAUSED BY FAT AND ALL IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH THE RATE
CONTINUING TO DOUBLE EACH YEAR.
IN MEETING FIRSTHAND WITH
PARENTS OF LOVED ONES WHO
SUCCUMB TO FATTEN ALL. A COMMON
TRAIT AROSE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. THESE PLATFORMS ARE
USED TO ADVERTISE IT MADE IT
EASIER TO PURCHASE FATTEN ALL
OVER THE INTERNET. WELL SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES HAVE INTRODUCED
NEW POLICIES TO ADDRESS DRUG
DISTRIBUTION THROUGH THEIR
PLATFORMS THIS PRACTICE IS NOT
WIDELY USE. GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT ARISES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS THERE
SHOULD BE SOME REQUIREMENT FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO POST
THEIR POLICIES IN AN AREA WHERE
PEOPLE CAN VIEW IT. AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO POST
POLICIES REGARDING THEIR POLICY
ON THE USE OF THE PLATFORM TO
ILLEGALLY DISTRIBUTE IT
DISTRIBUTE A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE. THIS BILL SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
A LINK TO THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS REPORTING MECHANISM
FOR ILLEGAL OR HARMFUL CONTENT
OR BEHAVIOR TO REPORT. WITH ME
TODAY IS SERGEANT JULIUS MISMA
CHRISTIAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAMBAR DINO SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JULIE IS A CHRISTIAN AND
I'M A SERGEANT REPRESENT A
SALMON COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE UNITED STATES AND
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCE OPEN
FIELDS. RELATED EPIDEMIC THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN CUT COMPOUNDED BY
THE INTRODUCTION OF FENTANYL AND
ITS CURRENT COUNTERPOINTS
COUNTERPARTS INTO THE DRUG
MARKET. IT NOW HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED IN HEROIN COCAINE
METHAMPHETAMINE AND MARIJUANA.
THAT KNOWLEDGE IS EXTREMELY
POTENT AND THE FAST ACTING AND
FAST ACTING IF INHALED OR
INGESTED. A DAILY DOSE OF FIT
NOW CAN BE USED AS LITTLE AS TWO
MILLIGRAMS IS FIFTY TIMES MORE
POWERFUL THAN HEROIN AND ONE
HUNDRED TIMES STRONGER THAN
MORPHINE. THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
NOTABLE CASES OF INDIVIDUALS
PURCHASING SUBSTANCES BELIEVING
THEM TO BE COCAINE
METHAMPHETAMINE OR PRESCRIPTION
PILL ONLY FOR THAT SUBSTANCE TO
BE LACED WITH DANGEROUS A
DANGEROUS QUALITY. OF FIT ENOUGH
THAT THE USER UNKNOWINGLY INGEST
. SOCIAL MEDIA IS THE LEADING
AVENUE THAT CONNECTS USERS AND
DEALERS THROUGH FRIEND
SUGGESTIONS. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD BE A
MAJOR ACID IN RESTRICTING THIS
ACTIVITY BY HAVING ALL ON ONLINE
PLATFORMS CREATE A POLICY
PROHIBITING THE USE OF THE
PLATFORM. TO ILLEGALLY
DISTRIBUTE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
CONFRONT THIS PROBLEM BY
REQUIREMENTS SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO HAVE POLICIES
PROHIBITING ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AND
REPORTING PROCESSES PREVENTING
pMEDIA. THIS WILL CREATE AN
OVERSIGHT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFIE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
ENSURE THAT POLICIES TO PREVENT
SUCH ILLIQUID ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
WERE IN PLACE AND WORKING AS A
AS INTENDED. I WANNA SAY THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS FIGHT
AGAINST THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND
HELPING US WE SEE THE TOOLS WE
NEED TO SAVE LIVES. FOR THOSE
REASONS I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT
AB. SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AND AN
URGENT IVEL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M JUST GOING TO.
FOR IT WE APPRECIATE THE TEST WE
WERE GONNA TAKE ONE MOMENT TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM SO AND
SECRETARY. APRIL HE PRESENT REAL
HERE KILEY- CAN. HERE BENNETT
HERE BERMAN CUNNINGHAM FONG FONG
HERE IRWIN BALLADARES HERE WICKS
WILSON. HERE WE HAVE SIX MEMBERS
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM- MISTER
ALMOST THANK FOR MUCH DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
TODAY. NOT TODAY OKAY IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AB IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS EDWIN
BARBON ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL AND I SEE THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION- LISTED
BUT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SOME OF OUR QUE
HAN AND THE SECOND. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR UNLESS I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN A THOUGHT LEADER ON THESE
ISSUES. APPRECIATE YOUR ADVOCACY
HERE- AND I THINK AS YOUR YOU
KNOW PROTECTING KIDS ONLINE IS A
MAJOR PARTY OF MINE- AND I AM.
PLEASED TO SEE YOU WORKING
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THE VERY REAL
PROBLEM OF DRUGS BEING SOLD ON
SOCIAL MEDIA I WANT TO THANK OUR
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE HERE WITH
US TO. LEND CREDIBILITY TO YOUR
APPROACH HERE AND TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND JUST WHAT A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THE SAYS AND
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN FAR TOO
MANY- YOUNG LIVES LOST. DURING
THE- EPIDEMIC THAT WE ARE FACING
IN OUR STATE AND OUR NATION- AND
I ALSO JUST WANT APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH MY
STAFF TO. WORK ON A MINUTES TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL SO I'M VERY
PLEASED AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY- AND HAPPY TO GIVE IT AN
IRATE PATIENT WITH THAT. MR
ALMOST YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND SHOWING THE
TESTIMONY FROM SNAPCHAT- RECORD-
SPONSORING AND SUPPORTING THE
BILL- THE SHOWS THAT WE'RE
WORKING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THIS. EPIDEMIC THAT'S GOING ON
IN OUR IN OUR NATION SO I WANNA
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES AND- AS FOR YOUR
RIVAL. ALL RIGHT ABSOLUTELY
THANK VERY MUCH OF THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED GABRIEL
HI GABRIEL I KILEY. BARRICADE
HAN BARRICADE HANDBAG BENNETT
BENNETT I BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM
FONG FONG I IRWIN. VALLADARES
BALLADEERS I'VE WICKS WILSON
WILSON I. HI THAT VOTE THE BILL
HAS EXPOSED TO TOP ORGAN HOLD ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR ALMOST SO MUCH
I NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE MOTION BY
THE MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN.
SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER WILSON
MEANT OF SECTOR CAN CALL THE
ROLL. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY MOTION
IS DUE PASS GABRIEL HI THE REAL
AYE KILEY. KILEY I BARRICADING
IN. BARRICADE HAND AYE BENNETT.
BENNETT I BERMAN CUNNINGHAM FONG
FONG I IRWIN VALLADARES
VALIDATORS I WICKS WILSON WILSON
I. THAT HAVE SEVEN VOTES OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED WE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I SEE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD HERE I'M
GONNA HAVE A FRIENDLY INVITATION
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
HIS STAFF. SO WE ARE GONNA
YOU'RE GONNA BE UP NEXT SOON SO
NOW WOULD BE A GOOD TIME TO MAKE
YOUR WAY OVER TO THE CAPITOL-
AND WITH THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WERE DELIGHTED TO SEE- COMMITTEE
WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE CHAIR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND THANKS TO THE
CONSULTANT FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
BILL. UNDER EXISTING LAW
PROPERTY MANAGERS MAY CHARGE UP
TO FIFTY THREE DOLLARS AND
THIRTY THREE CENTS PER SCREENING
REPORT FOR PROSPECTIVE RENTER.
DO THE CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS
RENTERS OFTEN HAVE TO APPLY TO
MULTIPLE PROPERTIES BEFORE THE
APPLICATION IS ACCEPTED. IF A
RENTER IS APPLYING TO SEVERAL
PROPERTIES THE VARIOUS
APPLICATION FEES CAN QUICKLY ADD
UP TO SEVERAL HUNDRED DOLLARS.
SO DO ADDRESSES FINANCIAL
BERRIER HOUSING WE'RE LOOKING TO
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON AND
MARYLAND WHO PASSED LEGISLATION
TO ALLOW LANDLORDS TO ACCEPT.
REUSABLE SCREENING REPORTS THESE
REPORTS ARE GENERATED BY A THIRD
PARTY SCREENING REPORT PROVIDERS
THAT WILL SECURELY GET GENERATE
AND SHARE A CERTIFIED SCREENING
REPORT WITH ANY PROSPECTIVE
LANDLORD. AN APPLICANT AB TWO
FIVE FIVE NINE CENTS A STATE
STANDARD FOR REUSABLE SCREENING
REPORTS TO BE USED DURING THE
RENTAL APPLICATION PROCESS IF
THE LANDLORD ELECTS. TO IT IF
THE LANDLORD ELECTS TO ACCEPT
SUCH A REPORT. BY USING A
REUSABLE SCREENING SUPPORT
RENTERS ONLY HAVE TO PAY A ONE
TIME. FOR THE REPORT THAT CAN BE
USED MANY TIMES OVER THIRTY DAY
PERIOD THEREBY SAVING THE RENTER
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS A MORE ALLOW
LANDLORDS. TO EXPEDITIOUSLY
REVIEW VERIFIED APPLICANT
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR EITHER. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. SOME OF OUR QUE
HANNAH SECOND BY- SWIMMER WILSON
OUR DYNAMIC DUO IN THE CORNER
OVER THERE- DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TODAY. NOT
TODAY WONDERFUL I AND I AM I DO
WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT- WE HAD
RECEIVED A LATE NOTICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HAVE
REALTORS HAS REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION IS NOW NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL. PLEASE WORK WITH THEM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OR IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. ANYONE IN
THE COULD HEARING ROOM I GUESS
WE WILL TURN TO OPPOSITION DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. FROM
SHORTER THAN THE LAST PERSON. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MY NAME
IS KELLY WALTERS I AM A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN I'M HERE
TODAY TO DISCUSS OUR OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO FIVE FIVE NINE AS IT
IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN. AS AN
INITIAL MATTER WE GENERALLY FIND
PORTABLE SCREENING REPORTS
BENEFICIAL FOR TENANTS AND
CONSUMERS ALIKE ADDITIONALLY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT LEGISLATION
THAT REDUCES THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN PLACED ON THOSE SIMPLY
SEEKING A PLACE TO LIVE IN
THEORY THIS BILL COULD BENEFIT
THOSE SEEKING HOUSING BY
ALLOWING THEM TO REUSE THEIR
SCREENING REPORT MULTIPLE TIMES
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS RATHER THAN
PAYING ANOTHER FEE EACH TIME
THEY APPLY FOR RENTAL. HOWEVER
THE PROPOSED BILL DEFINES A
REUSABLE TENANT SCREENING REPORT
TO INCLUDE THE RESULTS FOR AN
EXORBITANT AMOUNT OF TIME
SPECIFICALLY IT PROVIDES A
CRIMINAL AND EVICTION HISTORY
FOR THE PRECEDING SEVEN YEARS
SEVEN YEARS IS THE MAXIMUM LOOK
BACK PERIOD ALLOWED UNDER STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW. AS SUCH THE
AUTHORS OF AB TWO FIVE FIVE NINE
HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS IN THIS LOOK
BACK PERIOD. THE DANGER OF
CODIFYING THIS UNNECESSARILY
LONG LOOK BACK PERIOD COULD BE
DEVASTATING TO ANYONE RECENTLY
RELEASED FROM PRISON OR JAIL OR
ANYONE WITH A CRIMINAL HISTORY
WHICH WE ALL KNOW TO BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE OF
COLOR FURTHERMORE THIS BILL TO
CENTER VISES LANDLORDS USE THE
POTENTIALLY BENEFICIAL REUSABLE
TENANT SCREENING REPORT. AB TWO
FIVE FIVE NINE AS WRITTEN PUTS
OBLIGATIONS ONLY ON THE
LANDLORDS WHO USE THESE REPORTS
TO PROVIDE THAT NOTICE. THIS
BILL HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR
TENANTS BUT AS WRITTEN IT IS
LIKELY TO DISCOURAGE LANDLORDS
FROM USING THE PORTABLE
SCREENING REPORTS. AND WILL HAVE
A CHILLING EFFECT ON ANYONE WHO
HAS BEEN EVICTED OR HAS A
CRIMINAL HISTORY THAT EXTENDS
BACK TO SEVEN YEARS. FURTHER IT
WILL GIVE RISE TO VIOLATIONS OF
THE EQUAL PROTECTION OF VARIOUS
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. DUE TO THESE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS WE ARE BUT WE
ARE VERY OPEN TO WORKING WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. TO WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD'S
OFFICE TO MAKE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL THAT WOULD ELIMINATE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON THESE
TENANTS. BECAUSE OF ALL THESE
REASONS WE REQUEST THAT YOU VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL AS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO OUR IN
HOUSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND OR THE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. TO OUR MARKET.
I THINK THERE IS ONE OPPOSITION
LETTER ON FILE. THEIR THEIR LIST
OF THE- HI THEIR LIST AS PART OF
A COALITION SUBMITTING THE
LETTER. THERE ABOUT HOURS THANK
YOU I'M JUST SOME CLARIFICATION
SO IF I WERE A LANDLORD AND I
HAVE BEEN A ONE HOUSE THAT I'M
RENTING. AND I DON'T HAVE A
WEBSITE WHAT I AND I CHOOSE TO
USE THIS PROCESS. ONE WHAT I
HAVE TO ABIDE BY THE REST OF THE
CONTENTS AND IN MEANING IF I
DON'T HAVE A WEBSITE HOW CAN I
POST ON THE WEBSITE THAT THIS IS
WHAT I'M ACCEPTING- VERSES THAT
WOULD I JUST HAVE TO PUT ON LIKE
A CRAIGSLIST POST AND WERE HOT.
HOW WOULD WOULD I BE ABLE TO
COMPLY IF I DON'T HAVE ALL OF
THAT AND IF I DO IF IT DOESN'T
MATCH THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS
ISSUE HAS COME UP AND WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT THIS IS
ELECTIVE- THAT- WE WANT TO MAKE
IT EASY WE WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU
KNOW THIS NEW IDEA. INTO A AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY TO BE ABLE TO
USE SOMETHING THAT WILL REDUCE
COSTS FOR PROSPECTIVE RENTERS
ALSO WOULD BE MORE READILY
AVAILABLE TO OUR PERSPECTIVE
LANDLORD AS WELL- AND WOULD WORK
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMUNICATION IS CLEAR BETWEEN.
PROSPECTIVE LANDLORDS AND
PROSPECTIVE TENANT ON YOUR
EARLIER INTEREST IN ACCEPTING
HIS AS WELL- WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK- WITH OUR REALTORS IN THE
APARTMENT SAYS HE SHOULD MAKE
SURE THAT- THIS IS- PURELY
ELECTIVE. I'M JUST A LITTLE
CONCERNED ON HOW IT IMPACTS LIKE
THE LITTLE GUY ESPECIALLY IF-
I'M A LANDLORD AND I AM WILLING
TO ACCEPT THIS- TYPE OF APP
APPLICATION. AND FIND OUT AFTER
A MONTH OR TWO OF USINGIT BUT
IT'S JUST NOT WORKING FOR ME AND
I HOW WOULD I PROVIDE CLARITY SO
I'M NOT I DON'T FIND MYSELF IN
LEGAL TROUBLE THE FOLLOWING ONE
MOMENT WHEN I DECIDE THAT I
DON'T WANT TO USE THIS. AND THE
STATUTE OF A WRITING UNDER THIS
BILL WOULD AGAIN CONTINUE ALLOW
YOU THE FLEXIBILITY FOR HAVING
ELECTED TO BE GRATEFUL IF YOU
WOULD AS A LANDLORD CONSIDER
THAT- OF COURSE WE WANT TO TRY
TO PUT MORE OPTIONS OUT THERE
FOR PERSPECTIVE RENTERS- BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO INTRODUCE. A WAY
THAT DOES NOT HAVE AN INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. WERE PENALIZED.
ANY PARTICIPANTS. IT ALL JUST I
THINK YOU MUCH FOR THE- FOR THE
QUESTIONS. MEMBER I THINK AGO TO
WHAT COMMENTS YOU JUST MADE ALL.
AYE THOSE THAT WE FROM THE
OFFICE. WITNESS WE HAD SOME
ABOUT CONVERSE. ABOUT THIS IN
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AND NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS SAID ON
AND THERE'S A- DELICATE BALANCE
YOUR VARIOUS FACTORS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO DISCUSS TODAY- AND BE
MINDFUL OF THE COMMITTEE THE
LIMITS OF OUR COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION SO WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE PRIVACY ASPECTS
OF THIS BILL. IT'S ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD HAS WORKED WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO TAKE- SOME
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ROBUST PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF OTHER
ISSUES HERE- THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION I THINK ISSUES
THEY WERE RAISING BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO BE MINDFUL OF. THE
JURISDICTION OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE- AND KEEP OUR AND KEEP
OUR CONVERSATION TODAY FOCUSED
ON THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AND I
THINK. FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE-
THIS BILL YOU KNOW GETS A STRONG
RECOMMENDATION ON THE WAY THAT
IT PROTECTS THE PRIVACY OF THOSE
WHO WOULD BE FILLING OUT THESE
APPLICATIONS. JUST A- JUST A
PARENTHETICAL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS. I
GUESS I WOULD SAY A SIMILAR WORD
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD GOOD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS- IN IN
HOUSING AS I MENTIONED-
COMPLICATED ISSUE I THINK THIS
IS A- YOU KNOW THE IDEA OF
TENANT SCREENING REPORTS- ARE
ONE WAY OF MITIGATING THE
BURDEN- THAT WE FIND ON THOSE
WHO ARE SEARCHING FOR HOUSING I
THINK IT'S A REALLY THOUGHT
PROVOKING AN INTERESTING IDEA I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
IT- AND I APPRECIATE THE WAY
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS. AS YOU AND I KNOW
A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
HOUSING SPACE- TRYING TO CRAFT
SOMETHING THAT WORKS FOR FOLKS I
ALSO- HAVE CONFIDENCE PUTTING
THIS BILL THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
TODAY BECAUSE I KNOW YOU TO BE A
GREAT CHAMPION OF OUR PHONE OF
OUR COMMUNITY SOMEONE WHO IS
FOCUSED ON EQUITY AND ALL
PROTECTING TENANTS YOU HAVE A
RECORD THAT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF ON
THAT FRONT SO I'M CONFIDENT THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE. CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION- YOU KNOW THINK ABOUT
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS THAT FALL
OUTSIDE OF THE SCOPE OF THIS-
THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT AGAIN WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON TODAY IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING PRIVACY- I THINK
YOU'VE DONE A GOOD JOB I
APPRECIATE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE AGAIN THE STAFF TIME
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH MY STAFF
ON THE DETAILS OF COURSE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
ON MANY OF THE POINTS THEY REYES
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I
VOTE THIS WILL BE HELPFUL. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO FIVE FIVE NINE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED. AS AMENDED. GABRIEL
HI. GABRIEL I KILEY. KILEY AYE.
BARRICADE IN. AMERICA AND I'VE
BEEN IT. BENNETT I BERMAN.
CUNNINGHAM FONG. FONG I IRWIN.
BALLADARES NOT PUTTING. A
THERE'S NOT VOTING. WICKS
WILSON. WILSON I. HI SIX WHAT
YOUR BILL IS OUT WE WILL BE THE
AT ROLL OAKS AND PERHAPS A
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT AND WITH THAT
WE ARE WAITING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. I'M TOLD HE'S ON
HIS WAY.
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE'RE
DOING THE COMMISSION APPLE THIS
MORNING MISTER CHAIR- MISTER
BERMAN WE ARE GRACED BY YOUR
PRESENCE THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US AN HONOR TO BE HERE. OF
COURSE I WOULD LIKE TO THINK IT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. AS A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
NOTES I'LL BE ACCEPTING AN
AMENDMENT TO RESOLVE ANY
POTENTIAL AMBIGUITY AND CLARIFY
THAT EXPRESS WARRANTY WILL
COMMENCE. ON THE DATE OF
DELIVERY. CURRENTLY WHEN AN
EXPRESS WARRANTY COMMENCES AT
THE TIME OF PURCHASE THE
CONSUMER DOES NOT RECEIVE THE
FULL BENEFIT OR DURATION OF THE
WARRANTY IF THE PRODUCT DOES NOT
RECEIVE THE SAME DAY. THIS WAS A
PROBLEM PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
BUT IT'S ONLY GROWN MORE
APPARENT WITH PRODUCTS BEING
DELAYED WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS. FOR
EXAMPLE IF AN EXPRESS WARRANTY
IS GUARANTEED FOR ONE YEAR BUT
THE CONSUMER DOES NOT RECEIVE
THE PRODUCT FOR SIX MONTHS THEN
THE CONSUMER HAS ESSENTIALLY
LOST HALF OF THE WARRANTY. AB
TWENTY NINE TWELVE WOULD REQUIRE
EXPRESS WARRANTIES TO START NO
EARLIER THAN THE DATE OF
DELIVERY RATHER THAN THE DATE OF
PURCHASE. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THERE IS
PRECEDENT FOR HAVING WARRANTIES
BEGIN ON THE DELIVERY DATE.
CARPET INSTALLERS FOR EXAMPLE
TYPICALLY OPERATE THIS WAY. AND
THE EUROPEAN WARRANTY BEGINS
WHEN A PRODUCT IS RECEIVED NOT
PURCHASED. ADDITIONALLY
ACCORDING TO STATE LAW THE
DURATION OF WARRANTIES FOR
WHEELCHAIRS AND HEARING AIDS
ALREADY START FROM THE DATE OF
DELIVERY. AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE
IS SUPPORTED BY NUMEROUS
CONSUMER ORGANIZATIONS AND IS
RECEIVE NO OPPOSITION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ALL OF YOUR
AYE VOTES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION BY SOME OF OUR HANNAH
THE SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER. I
AND- I JUST WANTED ADD A THINK
WE HAVE LAY- LAW FROM THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION POLICY
COALITION AND THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION. A
MYSTERY OF ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TODAY WE DO NOT IN
PERSON NO SIR OKAY ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THE WISHES TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING DANNY
CANDOR BECAUSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT SEE NONE WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE ALREADY
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS HARD
QUESTIONS FOR MR BERMAN ANYONE
ELSE. ALL RIGHT CITIES SEEING
NINE MISTER BERMAN I WANT- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING FOR THE SPELL-
AND- I APPRECIATE THE WAY THAT
YOU HAVE- REALLY STEPPED UP TO
BE. A CHAMPION ON CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUES IS REALLY
CARVED OUT A NICHE FOR YOURSELF
IN THAT AREA- AND I THINK THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT GALLON
PARTICULAR WITH THE DELAYS THAT
WE'VE EEN. DURING THE PANDEMIC-
YOU KNOW IT'S BECOMING APPARENT
THAT OUR WARRANTY LAWS NEEDED TO
BE UPDATED TO. TO ENSURE THAT
WERE PROVIDING CONSUMERS WITH
THE FULL TEXT OF THOSE
WARRANTIES AND I THINK THE
APPROACH THAT YOU HAVE-
SUGGESTED MAKES SENSE IT'S AN
ELEGANT WAY TO DO IT- AND I'M
VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. SO WITH THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE THING I YEAH I WILL TAKE
THAT AS WELL AS MY CLOTHES THANK
YOU JOE GABRIEL. YOU GOT IT
THANK YOU- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED GABRIEL HI. I KILEY.
BARRICADE IN. THERE CAN I
BENNETT. BENNETT I BERMAN. HI.
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. FONG FONG I
IRWIN. BALLADEER NOT VOTING
BALLOT THERE'S NOT VOTER WICKS.
WILSON WILSON I. I WAS GONNA RUN
AWAY THE STATE IS HAS- EVEN
THOUGH IT YOU OFF GO HAS SIX
YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OF SIN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
LET'S- WE WANT TO GO BACK AND
ALLOW MISTER BERMAN TAT ON. OKAY. AS WITH AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. MOTION IS TO PASS- BERMAN
BERMAN HI. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTIES
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN
BERMAN HI. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
NINE BERMAN BERMAN HI CUNNINGHAM
IRWIN WICKS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO REOPEN THE ROLE ON A FEW
ITEMS MADAM SECRETARY AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED KILEY CUNNINGHAM-
WHEN- WHEN I WICKS. THAT THE
BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES WE WILL
pLEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS THOSE ON
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR CUNNINGHAM.
IRWIN WHEN I WICKS. THE BILL HAS
NINE VOTES WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN. AB TWO FIVE FIVE NINE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
CUNNINGHAM. IRWIN IRWIN I WICKS
. THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF CONTRACTS
IN MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
KILEY. CUNNINGHAM IRWIN- WHEN
I'VE WICKS. THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTE TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
PEOPLE WORK.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO RE OPEN
THE ROLE ON A NUMBER OF VOTES-
MEDICARE. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED KILEY. CUNNINGHAM WICKS
. WICKS I. THE BILL HAS NINE
ZERO IT IS OUT. AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY MOTION IS DUE PASSES ARE
CONSENT CALENDAR A CUNNINGHAM.
WICKS WICKS I. THAT BILLS OUT
TEN ZERO. AB TWO FIVE FIVE NINE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
CUNNINGHAM WICKS WICKS I. THE
BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED KILEY CUNNINGHAM
WICKS WICKS I. THOSE THAT BILLS
OUT. EIGHT ZERO.
ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES OUR-
HEARING TODAY I JUST WANT TO OF
COURSE THE KNOWLEDGE THE REALLY
HARD WORK OF OUR SECRETARY OF
THE CLERKS. OF THE ON-
CONSULTANTS ON BOTH SIDES THE
SERGEANTS EVERYONE FROM THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE SO THANK YOU
ALL AND WITH THAT THE HEARING IS
A DIRT.